u.s women's basketball star brittany
griner has gone on trial in russia for
alleged drug charges she's been held
there since february reiner declined to
enter a plea on friday but said she may
do so at a later date the phoenix
mercury center appears to be at the
center of what may be some kind of
prisoner swap between washington and
moscow charlie dagda reports
in a jimi hendrix t-shirt and handcuffs
brittany griner was whisked into a
closed door hearing the first in what
could be a months-long trial the wnba
star is facing drug charges for
allegedly carrying vape cartridges
filled with cannabis oil through a
moscow airport in february she has yet
to file a plea but could spend as many
as 10 years in prison if convicted u.s
embassy representative elizabeth rude
was in the courtroom she is doing as
well as can be expected in these
difficult circumstances and she asked me
to convey that she is in good spirits
and is keeping up the faith
but it will take more than faith to
secure her freedom more than 99 percent
of prosecutions in russia end in
conviction it's not a question of
whether or not she will be convicted
it's a question of what she will be
convicted on
you're guilty it's just a question of
what degree of guilt from their
perspective
the u.s state department has said the
two-time olympic gold medalist has been
wrongfully detained and has vowed to do
everything possible to secure her
release
russian media has speculated that griner
might be part of a prisoner swap with
russian arms dealer victor boot known as
the merchant of death currently serving
a 25-year sentence in a federal prison
for cbs saturday morning charlie dagetta
london
it's been really interesting since this
happened since she was detained watching
nba and wnba players making certain that
nobody would forget that brittany
greiner was there by saying if this was
steph curry if this was lebron name you
know enter nba player's name
people would not would this be the same
right yeah yeah it's it's certainly
something that they've made certain is
in the consciousness and she's one of
many americans detained in venezuela
iran and other countries as well and one
that you know obama administration
continues to keep it close eye on for
sure